so I got two questions for you so one is
so the part about you can hand the phone
over and not give the password what
happens if I do that you're the FBI
agent you're stuck I say here's my phone
that you've actually you've complied
with the warrant you asked me for
password if I say I'm not going to give
it to you what can you do so what they
can do is they can they could try to
bring you before a court under a
contempt threat of contempt and try to
get you to compel to give you the
password but those cases are limited to
National Security where there's imminent
threat to National Security okay so
people so so perfect so Peter struck
yesterday not yesterday a couple days
ago tweets this on September 14th he
tweets this and I would share it but I'm
uncomfortable it may drop you so we're
not going to risk sharing and we'll
share it afterwards he says uh at this
point FBI may have more cell phones than
Verizon okay than a Verizon store
Giuliani uh Victoria towns Inc Michael
McDonald Scott Perry is referencing you
John Eastman Jeff Clark Boris Epstein
Mike Roman Mike Lindell and then this is
the last sentence and this is a question
for you and and Congressman Perry the
FBI can't seize any of them without
probable cause they contain evidence of
a crime is he right about that last
statement all right so what the reason
why I asked the congressman now it
doesn't necessarily mean that the
congressman and by the way again I'm not
trying to encroach your learning Council
but that a affidavit in support of a
search warrant does have to suggest that
there's crime there's criminal there's
fruits that may be borne out in seizing
that item that doesn't necessarily mean
the recipient of the search warrant is a
target or a subject of the criminal
activity the congressman could have been
talking to or communicating with someone
else who may be the subject in Target
but and that begs a little bit of the
rub here because generally speaking in
my world they would be able to get that
side of the conversation through that
other individual meaning serve the
execute execute the warrant against that
other individual so if there's a search
warrant that was executed for the
seizure of the congressman's phone there
is an affidavit that's under sealed by
the way and this is different than
Donald Trump his affidavit he does not
and I will assume Congressman you
haven't been given the affidavit correct
I have not I'm not but I generally
but we confirmed we confirmed that day
with the Department of Justice my
attorneys confirmed that I am not the
target of the investigation from taking
the phone so that tells me then someone
that he was talking to or allegedly yeah
someone he was communicating with is a
target or subject of a criminal
investigation and either their content
of that communication is unavailable or
no longer available and the only way
they were trying to then get that
communication was through this witness
so these so the congressman at best
would be a witness so so then so then
this the last question and then uh
Congressman Perry if you got any final
thoughts for the audience or any
rebuttal on what I'm asking here is so
what if in that moment the three FBI
agents are standing in front of New
Jersey uh waterfront home that he's on
vacation for uh for a month in the month
of August it's August 14th I believe
it's a date what if in that moment he
says to his one of his kids hey guys can
you go to the garage grab a hammer bring
the hammer out and I start breaking the
phone I think somebody's done this
before in the past what if he starts
breaking the phone right in front of you
immediately arrested and charged with
obstruction of justice immediately how
come that didn't happen in the past well
look the difference is and I know who
we're talking about of course okay
sweetheart so she listened but she was
not the recipient at the time she took
chemicals in a sledgehammer to destroy a
uh a computer server
had she done that in realizing that a
that a search warrant was imminently
being served upon her and did that that
individual would be charged with
obstruction and tampering and destroying
of evidence so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]